serions nous revenu au 18e siècle tout
du moins le temps d'un après midi
dimanche 11 octobre domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles une petite troupe
a défilé en costumes d'époque
à l'occasion de l'exposition marie
antoine new look de la photographe
amateur depuis 20 ans taha soultane à
marie-antoinette new look c'est une
rencontre avec marie antoinette
lorsque je travaillais au château de
versailles
j'étais dans l'accueil et la
surveillance et comme je ne lâche
pratiquement pas un appareil photo je
crois que c'est marie antoinette qui
lorsqu'elle m'a vu passer elle a deux se
dire tiens c'est la bonne personne
c'est la personne idéale pour me sortir
du trianon débuté le 7 octobre dernier
l'exposition est un mélange de
photographies et d'arts visuels
l'artiste a décliné à 14 reprises la
photo d'un buste de la reine un travail
numérique
en fait mon travail c'est un petit peu
comme c'est le pot même procédé que la
peinture abstraite de travail partouche
les couleurs se diffuse un petit peu et
ensuite je dois chercher les endroits où
il faut poser telle couleur telle
couleur une exposition pensée pour
étonnés émerveillés ou encore émouvoir
tout un programme à découvrir jusqu'au
18 octobre